Pope Francis calls an apparent chemical
attack in Syria an unacceptable massacre
we must warn you here that the video of
the aftermath is very disturbing the
attack reportedly killed at least 72
people the images appear to show victims
reacting to the use of a nerve agent the
White House claims the government of
Syrian President Bashar al-assad who
calls the attack and series it Lib
province heinous Holly Williams is along
the turkey-syria border with details of
the attack now described as a war crime
Holly good morning good morning some of
the victims of this attack are now being
treated at a hospital not far from here
the Turkish Health Minister said today
that initial findings show this was a
chemical weapon
[Music]
survivors of yesterday's suspected
chemical attack are ferried out of the
war zone and over the border to Turkey
the assault on the village of harsh iron
bears all the hallmarks consistent with
a chemical weapon many of the dead and
injured had no visible wounds as you'd
normally expect from an airstrike or
missile survivors had breathing problems
some foaming at the mouth and their
pupils didn't respond to light all of
that strongly suggests exposure to a
nerve agent the Syrian regime denies
responsibility and so does its ally
Russia though both have targeted a blue
province with air strikes the Russian
explanation is that a Syrian strike hit
an ammunition depot containing chemical
weapons run by rebel forces at around
12:00 noon yesterday but a chemical
weapons expert and CBS contributor says
even if that's true it wouldn't produce
an aftermath like this and multiple
witnesses including dr. Islam schedule
treated survivors and is also an
opposition activists say the attack
happened hours before the Russians claim
we sent a lot of patients to Turkey and
Turkey are now taking samples from these
patients and soon we will know for a
fact what this chemical was but we have
a high level of suspicion that this was
sorry in gas that was used that same
deadly substance sarin nerve agent was
used in a 2013 attack in Syria thought
to have killed hundreds of people the US
and other countries blamed the Syrian
regime the UN Security Council will hold
an emergency meeting later on today
Norah absolutely barbaric we'll see if
there's more than just a meeting Holly
Williams in Turkey thank you